I did want to mention at this point that
there are other viewpoint controls. There's an initial scale property
that let's you set what the browser's initial scaling factor
will be. It defaults to one and usually, you don't
really want to mess with it. If you change it to
another number, this changes the initial zoom factor. And the
user will probably have to pan or zoom. There is
one very critical use to initial scale though. On iOS,
if you only set width to device width and
you don't set the initial scale, like in this page,
when you rotate the screen the iOS web engine
will keep the same view port width and rescale it
to fit across the landscape screen. It's just stretching
the portrait layout, to fit, across the landscape width. Even
though I've set width to device width, IOS is
still scaling the landscape width. In fact, the interesting bit.
is that even if you load this page initially
in landscape mode, it still thinks it's the portrait
width, it just rescaling it to fit in the
landscape screen. Now, if you have the same page,
but you set the initial scale to 1 in
the viewport meta-element along with setting device width, it'll
change the viewport size when you rotate, instead of
rescaling. You can see now the window size is 480
pixels across. It's the landscape width, not the
portrait width. So, in short, this is what
you really need to use as your default
boiler plate viewport meta-element. You'll need the initial scale,
so that IRS, when flipping from portrait to
landscape mode will still scale correctly. An interesting side
note I discovered is that on Iphones -
Although they are changing the viewport size properly if
an initial scale is that, they are also
changing the default font size for the document
and orientation change, effectively zooming up the text
when you go to landscape mode. This means
you should probably set a default font size
on the page, not just use an percentages.
You may want to use a reset style sheet to do this, if you aren't already.